i don't know who wants to come to a city
like austin be told to go out there
swear an oath to protect and defend this
community protect the people in the
lives of many protect the property of
this community only to go out there and
do just that to be told you know what
we're going to indict you and
potentially put you away for the rest of
your life in prison
so this war on policing is real they
couldn't get away with defunding us so
now they're trying to indict us the
allegations be made against me by jose
garza is aggravated assault
with the deadly weapon by a public
servant a first degree felony which
carries a life a potential life sentence
we were responding to a riot you know
people throwing molotov cocktails at us
bottles frozen water bottles bottles
filled with urine bottles full of
gasoline and they're engaging in in
criminal activity by obstructing the
passage road that goes to the main
hospital
so no we weren't our actions were not
unlawful by any means at all we were
responding to the behavior and the
actions of those that were out there
committing crimes breaking the law and
refusing the numerous warnings that were
given to them
um to disperse this is the largest you
know case of batch of pushed indictments
of officers first time ever in american
history and again that makes you ask
yourself why it's politically motivated
this has nothing to do with justice has
nothing to do with any wrongdoing this
is simply about politics and a political
agenda that's taking place with his
radical uh liberal uh district attorneys
i mean look what's taking place is
happening during a primary right now
it's messing with my election it's it's
you know
granted i've been a very outspoken
critic of his for all the radical stuff
he's doing letting violent criminals
back in the streets putting sex
offenders child molesters back on our
streets and so yeah i've been very vocal
he's had two years go through and move
forward with this but he waits till
right now wait still a primary that's
taking place to meddle in that
um you know and i'm not going to be
intimidated by that this is a war on
policing i mean look at it and this has
been going back you know here in austin
this started back in 2017 with our
radical liberal city council when they
voted to withhold uh our pay stipends
and then you see what's going on with
taking our ability to uphold the law and
enforce the law you got judges that are
no longer doing their duty in upholding
law they're releasing violent criminals
it gets frustrating you know you have
you talk to business owners you talk to
victims and they're like i call y'all
but you don't come i call you but you
can't do anything it's hard to hear no
wonder people are frustrated you can't
blame them you can't blame them for
getting frustrated look at our homicide
rates they're through the roof right now
and you look at anywhere george soros
has planted his one of his da's in there
it's gone to chaos and destruction you
know austin wants you to be this great
thriving town where
young adults from across the country
love to come too because there's a
vibrant entertainment district great
food uh just very kind people and now
look at you got homeless issues through
through the roof trash and garbage all
over the green belts and the waterways
crime's running rampant people no longer
feel safe businesses are shutting down
community members are moving out of the
town
yeah it is an impact and now look at
then and look at what's left take out
the policing the war on policing is
coming next because we're in their way
uh from upholding constitution we're in
their way from creating anarchy and
destroying this town so if they can't
defund us and get rid of us that way now
they're going to try and de-police us by
sending us to prison and indicting us
everyone's watching this every cop right
now in the united states of america is
watching what's taking place because if
it's happening here it very well could
happen there too
you